[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning as we
cover the
51st earth day here at cbs news you've
probably noticed that a lot of the world
is covered in pavement and that's
creating a problem whenever it rains
take a look at the blue areas on this
map right here
it's where we find places where the rain
cannot be absorbed into the ground where
it falls instead
it runs off the pavement and into nearby
waterways carrying pollutants like
fertilizer oil pesticides
and bacteria in many places it also
forces
raw sewage to spill into the water
but there is good news we're happy to
report we found a lot of people
working to fix this problem
on a windy day north of new york city
this is a magnificent
majestic river john lipscomb helped a
certain land lover understand the life
of his favorite waterway
one thing i cannot figure out is if the
is the water flowing that way or that
way
right now it's going that way as a
member of the environmental group
riverkeeper lipscomb has been patrolling
the hudson river for decades
marveling as saltwater from the ocean
flows up
but also worrying about what's flowing
in every time it rains
bottle caps cigarette butt you name it
that's a visual indicator of what the
storm water has carried off the streets
into the river
but it's what we can't see that's the
bigger concern
we watched as columbia university
researcher elise myers took samples
nearby
when we have a lot of these areas where
the water just runs straight off it can
carry whatever's on here so
trash but also chemicals and things like
that and in urban areas where you have
that high concentration definitely
something to be worried about
the epa calls polluted runoff one of the
greatest threats to clean water
here on the hudson marshes are really
critical to ecosystems
when we think about wetlands in general
myers had a standing ankle deep in
something you can describe with one word
or many but here i'm seeing a lot of
bacteria that usually we only find
inside the guts of warm blooded animals
like ourselves
and so when we find them in the water
it's an indication that we have some
sort of sewage contamination
what you're telling me is the toilets
have a way of ending up
at least in part here yes unfortunately
there's definitely
a way that something you have flushed
down some of those bacteria can end up
out here
she says rain can overwhelm sewage
treatment plants
and in nearly 800 cities across the u.s
raw
sewage overflows into the water by
design in a downpour
those cities have what are known as
combined sewer systems
where the stuff that goes down our
drains at home mixes with the stuff that
washes off our streets
when it rains instead of backing up into
our homes those systems can release a
mix of sewage
and polluted storm water and as we
travel
down into new york city john lipscomb of
riverkeeper showed us some of the
hundreds of points
in this area alone where sewage enters
the water
that opening under the wall there that's
a combined sewer overflow
they have a sign up that says caution
it's permitted city has said
this is what we must do because we can't
do better
and the state okays it those are state
permits
and the epa knows it and the epa is of
course the federal agency that oversees
all the states so at every level of
government this is not a secret
not a secret why is it not a scandal
because most people don't know about it
yet it is something the new york city
department of environmental protection
is working to address
look at that deputy commissioner angela
licotta showed how the city is trying to
keep water out of the system
with surfaces that can absorb more of it
into the ground
this synthetic turf here is designed
to hold about a million gallons of storm
water a year
so without these changes all that would
have run over
the regular old road and ended up in the
drain exactly
the city is also redirecting storm water
into thousands of tiny rain gardens
designed to soak up runoff
and it's built massive tanks that can
hold tens of millions of gallons of
sewage that would otherwise spill into
the water
it spent billions on these projects and
seen some results
the amount of combined sewage overflow
has dropped 26
since 2008 and more than 80 percent
since the 1980s
it's been a tremendous improvement now
it's finishing the job
it's clean enough now for many here to
get out and enjoy it
at least in dry weather how was the
water so much fun
but even if it doesn't make you sick i
couldn't say anything bad about it we
definitely got hit and
sprayed a lot finding out that 20
billion gallons of sewage still gets
released here every year
could make anyone think twice 20 billion
good enough for you guys could be better
2020 sounds like a lot
so as environmental leaders figure out
how to stop toxins from entering the
water
so we're heading over to our oyster reef
cabinets
people like rabina taliaferro are
working on a way to clean up what's
already here
she's part of the billion oyster project
installing oyster reefs in new york
harbor
what they do is they help clear the
water a single adult oyster can filter
50 gallons of water every day they will
pull
out of the water those particles those
things do you know what yes
you know what so they will pull that and
actually
create like a casing and drop it to the
bottom
of the water column so they help they
help they help to a certain degree
but john lipscomb says a complete fix
will require
more money and that means more pressure
from the public
we've got a a vehicle driving around on
mars right now
and we've walked on the moon don't tell
me this can't be done
that's a good point it makes a good
point
he's got he's got a lot of passion but
here's the problem all the cities that
have been built
in america you can't just lift them up
uh on a crane and change all the
plumbing yeah that's the issue it would
cost
billions of dollars to do it and it's
all funded by sewer and water rates
which have been going up and people
can't afford them right so
we're stuck i'm encouraged that we've
come as far as we have i didn't realize
we'd made that much progress but 20
billion is still a lot here in new york
and it's billions in other cities as
well yeah i'm still thinking that every
time you flush your toilet
where that stuff goes yeah i just don't
think that it i didn't know where it
went today because when it rains
they have a choice it either backs up
into your home which no one wants or
that
it goes out into the water i don't want
that no